Good afternoon. Google. Good. Good.
That everybody's awake.
Uh,
so welcome to the talks at Google on
personal branding and negotiation.
We are really, really glad to
have an esteemed panel here.
I'm going to quickly introduce this,
even those also cosponsored
by the women at Google.
We've been trying to get this
audience for a long time,
so thank you so much for making it here.
A quick introduction on all of them.
So luxury right next to me is
had two decades in marketing,
was a venture capitalist and as an
entrepreneur now she started ink India in
partnership with Ted and has worked with
Intel global capitalist partners and
American Indian Foundation in Aif.
She founded the FS
digital equalizer program,
which offers technology education to
80,000 children and 20,000 school teachers
here in India.
Uh,
I don't know how many of you remember
the massive dead that happened in 2009 in
my soul in the Infosys campus.
Uh,
she actually brought Ted to India
and also some of the wonderful talks.
I know Sunita oppressions talk product
mysteries talk was very, very popular.
They with a partner as well and she's
been responsible pro all the talks and
storytelling that some of these
esteemed speakers have done. Uh,
sh she claims that one of our favorite
interviews, and I heard it last week was,
is the one with Andy Grove who was the
co founder for a co founder of Intel.
So welcome flux me.
Thank you.
We have our next [inaudible].
So [inaudible] is a name
well known in Hyderabad. Uh,
she's the COO of mapped my genome and an
alumnus of [inaudible] as well as an ms
from University of Illinois.
Uh,
I have read some of articles
in Linkedin and what really,
really amazed me is a poem that
she's written on cancer mutation with
chromosomal combinations. So people don't
think that art and science go together,
but she's a living example
of art and science together.
So great storytelling
and writing is a forte.
She'll talk a little bit about it as well.
And she has several feathers in a cap
being named as one of the youngest global
leaders by the World Economic Forum.
[inaudible]
oh, so we have reduced Tanisha. So next,
she's a founder of a health and weight
loss coaching tech startup called Obino.
It's a 4.5 star rated app
on Google play and uh,
so you should definitely
go and check it out.
She's had an illustrious career spanning
from radio where she had content for FM
93.5.
She's also led brand for about the hotel
and there's now an entrepreneur welcome
to too
[inaudible]
and I don't know why he
did needs introduction, but
I'll still do the honors.
Good on the global campaign operations,
which is now spread across 15 countries.
Uh,
he's been the Google for the past 10 years
and leads a team of digital marketing
professionals and engineers focusing
on ensuring that clients marketing
objectives are met with the right product
expertise. So thank you for being here.
Thank you.
We've stopped the introduction,
the Google Vr with a fun fact.
So we usually do this in Google.
So we'd like to hear one less known or
a fun fact from each, a few Lakshmi.
Um, God, everything about me,
I lay my life on my sleeves. I
don't know what about me. Um,
I used to act in theater.
I did my MBA with a minor in theater and
I taught that that would work it in 10
for two years, save enough money and
moved to La and become an actress.
But I fell in love with technology
and kept thinking, okay, next year,
next year, next year, and then
realized at 28 that I'm too old. So
that's good.
Um, so I think that was one. So, Oh God,
by the police. I feel wondering
why we were in graduate school.
Love it.
The uh,
organizing fully and we messed
up a brand new dance load, so
I won't, I'll tell the whole
story at some other point.
One for someone who runs a weight loss
coaching startup you and hopefully it
doesn't show, when you look at me,
I can out eat anyone in this room.
So when I got the mattered
and we went on our honeymoon,
my husband who had not
seen my true colors chill,
you belonged to want to botch up.
And Carola and my dad had organized
my favorite dinner for me,
which was like this huge
heaping mound of Kettler.
Horizon three big different
abuzz of various fish.
Corinne's and my husband watched
quantified fascination.
I proceeded to eat
something that is like not good.
Don't do you want to approach it?
I do too.
Anything is left off my [inaudible]
sorry.
You think I have um, uh, given a doll.
So maybe one continuing on
the universities for this,
I was detained for a few hours in a police
station and it was not as trivial as
messing up with a dance floor.
It does a little more serious than that,
but I didn't live it.
I bet.
So. Okay. So moving on door,
Boston running on one started,
I know you started in a regular it and
then went to do a data analyst job,
but now you a strong brand for yourself,
probably the most recognized brand in the
field of genetic research in India. Um,
so how did you evolve your personal
branding one and then how do you tie it to
the organization that you lead now?
And I know that you write a lot,
so how does that help with
building the site and, sure.
So I think in the Indian,
yeah,
I believe that any brand,
whether it's a personal loan or a company,
is when you are authentic
and true to yourself.
So I think what I've done all my
life is just to figure out who I am.
And uh, so part of our identity as
mapped my genome is also noise itself.
But it was through a
process of understanding and
discovering myself that I
think I evolved in the beginning.
I would say when we started or Simone,
which was my first startup,
it was primarily to see how do you build
the business up in us in an area that
we don't know anything about.
So part of it was building connections,
building relationships, uh, without
expecting something from them.
And I think I started looking
on that in the beginning,
but over a period of time, I think
it, it sort of evolved. I start,
you start doing what you really
enjoy most, which is actually saying,
what do you get? You know, what do you
like about that particular relationship?
So when it was a personal relationship,
it was very clear what,
what would be expected.
But building relationships on,
they'd say linkedin or social
media was a very different thing.
So what a period of time.
I think that the world,
and I also am a very quirky
and a very strange, you know,
I have my own strange habits, but
I started picking on that. Right?
So you say you're, if you're going to, I
used to write limericks even in school,
uh, but I use that as a process
of understanding new subjects.
So science was one of the
first things when we started,
we bought a company in the U S I was
trying to explore something in order to
summarize, I would start writing. So
part of it was just being myself, uh,
but you know, just expressing. And
I think as we started growing and,
uh,
it started a divorce.
And so I've never really planned
to build a story around it,
but I think it was just
being who I happened and,
and I think it's continue to do that.
So I think this,
just that now that you've been doing it,
so many times,
people start seeing patterns in
it. So that's, that's about it.
But I think in the end it was just me.
[inaudible] you said, oh, Noi yourself.
And I know the two you
speak a lot about uh, uh,
your health transformation story,
uh,
from being an j to really being an
entrepreneur of a health startup.
And Donna's point of knowing your self
view while the spoken about how brand
should be a reflection of
your value system. Do you
want to talk about that? So,
um, when I was part of the
brand team at et and uh,
we actually delve really deep into what
a brand is and in the most simple manner
that you can break it down.
A brand is a series of associations
that people have off you.
They may be visual,
they maybe be process based,
but they associate you with a
certain set of characteristics.
And that's how personal brands a built.
And I think
when she said, know yourself, she
really put her finger on it because, um,
when you build yourself as a
brand and as an entrepreneur,
you have to do that everyday because
of the early stages. Investors,
customers invest on the phone.
Do they trust the founder? Did.
There is no company that is hardly any
team that are placing their bets on you
and it is that intangible quality,
which is your personal brand,
which actually leads to that investment,
whether it's off a smaller ticket size
as a customer or as a large ticket size
as an investor.
And what I realized is you may want to
come across in your personal brand as
sophisticated urbane and witty,
but you may actually be that person who
can sit and have four portfolios of fish
courier to go and you should celebrate
that because that is what makes you
unique. That is what makes you stand
out in a cluttered marketplace.
So I'm a decently dressed today,
but I have a data blue sense of fashion.
My own husband cringes at mine dressing
choices and I've always been like that.
I've been that way since my college days.
But for me and for my investors that's
come to stand for how little the regular
pursuits off looking good
and vanity mean to be.
And that says something about who I am.
You may not be something that
they aspire to or understand,
but it makes me very clearly
identifiable as a kind of person.
And that's what we should do.
We should look at what's core to us,
not stuff that we really like about
ourselves, but which we really are.
Take that, spin it and make it work
for you. Perfect. So you said, yeah,
so you need to do,
you brought a very good point.
It is like what you are the cord
and celebrity also. So those are,
I think fundamentals on
what we base our brand.
So moving to something which is close
to all of the Google is working on a
remote office and that often comes up.
We've heard a lot of infighting
branding stories from outside of Google,
but close to home. What's the
magic mantra? And Google for it,
especially growing businesses from
a remote location and letting the
headquarters know that this is the brand
of India. How, how to do it. I'll do
go about it. Yeah. And I, you know,
my answer wouldn't be like as much of
a talk through strategy because when we
started we never really taught
that this is what we will achieve.
But I think it was a lot
around, um, uh, you know,
taking in a lot of the opportunities that
came in the way. But a few things that,
uh,
you know,
we need to be aware when you are dealing
with a remote location and especially
Google being a very headquarter
centric company, uh, anyone,
and this is not just from India,
but maybe in a dub in Dublin or in
Singapore or anywhere, anywhere else,
dependability factor has to
be very high. Uh, so, uh,
the company is trusting the region or
the operations with someone who needs to
be very dependable,
a aligned,
understand the signals and uh,
react or act fast.
Right? Uh, so that's one
and I think over the PDL,
and these are things which might
sound as I have a, uh, um, uh,
sounding a bit wise, but it's
all looking backwards. Um, uh,
what I understood from my, um,
you know, from others, you know,
we have this fantastic Google guys
feedback and all that is a few things that
have stood out for me is a dependable,
perseverant and I'm grounded.
I think these are some of the things, and
you know, again, back to the point, uh,
you know, that our new raised was,
you know, be what you are. Uh,
you know,
many times at Google we
have seen different kind of
leadership and we ask buyer
to or get inspired by
certain kinds of leadership.
But what I have reconciled
pretty early is be what you are.
And these are the traits that define me
and these are the traits that perhaps
helped me function in a global set up,
much effective.
And, and that's fair because everybody
has their own strengths and areas for
development.
And really playing to your strength and
being authentic is probably the way to
go. Uh, you also spoke about
reliability and being disciplined,
which I think is a score of
walking the Moto Mod authors.
So we'll talk a little more about it,
but back to luxury and luxury,
you worked with brand on people and
especially storytelling and you self
described yourself as a people collectors.
We all would like to know what does the
tone people collective bead and how do
you associate a personal
brand with storytelling?
Because that's the key to really
opposite of that. You know, we, you know,
one of the things I love doing is working
with people on telling their stories
and uh, as everybody said, you know,
you want in the conversations to look
for what makes them them, you know,
and you want to keep that because it's
not about making them all sound great.
Great.
It's about making them all sound like
themselves and be comfortable with it. Um,
so that is one thing I learned and it,
you know,
and actually I learned so much about
what I do in my theater than I did in my
Mbas.
So one of the things they teach you in
theater is called playing the opposite,
you know, so it's sort of, if
you're really angry, you know,
you yell and scream,
it's one level of being angry.
But if you're really like quiet
and then you say, you know what,
I want to kill you tomorrow. It's
like, it's more scary, you know?
So I've really learned that
because it's sort of as a person,
especially when I went to Portland,
Oregon where 92% white people,
and here I am like this
little brown thing.
I was the only Indian in like the entire,
uh,
my professors have ever
worked with I think.
And they can place me because here I
am doing MBA when I do my theater and
creative writing and they thought
Indians were like very meek and quiet.
And here I was like not quite
making the and all that stuff.
So I'm like playing, you know, so
it took me a while to figure it out.
But I think playing the opposites, that
is an amazing way of building your brand,
not playing, but you are multiple
things and it's okay to be things.
I may wear
a sari and I might swear I'm aware a
very western outfit and be completely
traditional.
So we sometimes often confuse what
we try to be with what we are.
And I think it's okay to be opposite.
And then I'll open it to all four of you.
Can you give me an example of where
this personal branding and authenticity,
like all of you talked about really
has helped you in your career?
That one point where you said, no,
I'm going to completely shun my,
what I'm pretending and being from
my normal and this is what I am.
This is my brand. And it worked
for you. Do you have examples?
So I take a shot at it. Um, so when I,
when we raised our first
round of funding sec,
actually third round of funding from
roundglass partners that are us based
health care. We see, uh,
we got APPS, actually,
we've got about seven minutes
with the founder of the fund.
And we drove all the way across
town of whole Phalange of us.
And they were like 30 of them and if
we're all expecting to make up page,
and he just walked and he said,
why don't we take a walk? And I,
my entire team was holding their Max and
their presentations and we just took a
walk. And in that five minutes he said,
tell me a story. So for the second,
I was lost.
I had the entire 10 slide pitch deck
and how much money I wanted to raise.
And he's like,
tell me your story.
And I just told him my story of coming
down from 75 kilos back to 50 kilos and
why I felt this was something that I
could do for the rest of my life because
I'd been through a really shitty phase
in my life and I wanted to make sure that
people didn't have it that shitty.
He gave me like exactly seven minutes
at the end of it, he says, create,
what are we signing the
papers? Uh, I didn't,
I really didn't have an answer.
And I think at moments like that when
you don't have a chance to prepare,
when you're expecting something to happen
in something totally different happens,
you are what you are because there's
nothing else you've prepared to be.
And that is the truest reflection of who
you are and people who can see that and
judge it and what would
be part of that journey.
I think they're very lucky
to find those people.
And that Prince of good point too,
because it was also about self realization
because it's very important that all
of us understand what we stand for.
And it's important for us not
to pretend to be what we are.
And that realization often we don't spend
enough time introspecting and figuring
out what are we, what is our
strength? Right. Um, so, um,
I know you spoke about a means to an
end because you spoke about, okay,
personal branding is the end,
but there is a way you,
you're writing has helped
to get to that end.
What are some of the other things that
you have used or tools that you've used
or processes we've used to
really get clear end goal?
I think,
you know,
for me the last 16 years at least has
been primarily about my two startups.
Uh,
I also
have two babies, but that you don't
grow the babies now. Uh, but, uh,
I think for me it was always
about saying, you know, you are,
you're very encrusted the business,
but you were more in grocery chain.
How do you build a team and so on.
Right? So part of it was building that,
that culture, and it's strange
because you use, don't realize it,
but it's sort of half has an effect on
the rest of the people that you have
around you. And a, so I was
primarily busy and creating that,
uh, and not trying to
put on any, you know,
a different shades to myself and just
being who I am when I interview people,
you know,
you interviewed them as normal people and
not have the same set of questions and
those kinds of things.
So I think part of your identity sort
of them sort of builds over to the
business as well.
And whether it is mapped my genome where
currently I think we have some billion
people also,
you know,
as part of the team and all of that I
think comes in because you truly want
people to, to become, you know,
to create something that you,
you wish you can transform the
world and to be able to do that.
And I think part of that has to
do with how you are as, as I know,
and as long as you are
open to being a saying,
I do know I could be completely
exposed and still you are,
people will want to work for me. I
think, you know, that's when you,
I think if you can build a good team,
right?
So I think you need to be honest with
yourself and you need to be open and
transparent.
And I think the moment you do that,
I think part of your
brand builds around that.
And a lot of that reflection I see near
writing because I think you've used that
as a means to really convey your branding.
And so I,
I mean now I've started writing, now I'm
not nurses. So for instance, you know,
I've have political views,
I'll have uh, views on science.
I have used on, you know, feminism, I'll
have used a lot of different things. Uh,
initially I used to be an instigator so
I would love to get five people together
at Torrisi purchase like though and get
people to start talking because when we
are in that heated moment,
especially when it comes to things
like politics or cricket or you know,
whatever it is that people
have polarizing views on,
I think all you need is a little later
on I realized that, you know, my job was,
you know,
it's fun to be an instigator but it's
probably more fun if you can actually put
some of your, what you really think
about something but do it in a non, uh,
not a way to really get people to start
fighting with each other and understand
him. How do you come up with something
creative and, and uh, you know,
something that we can all start
thinking positively about. Right?
So I think I have gone through a lot
of transformation in my own life.
So your by writing, so also sort
of reflect that. So you know,
I've written a book on poetry,
but if I read through what I wrote
in 2010 versus what I liked in 2016,
I think that shows the transformation
of who, what I have become.
And you don't realize it at that point.
But part of it is that one of
the things is that when I write,
I could always go back and see how was
I as a person at that point. Right.
And then you can verify it with other
people who were there around because you
might not be the best judge.
So I think I've gone through some of
that phases that you're seeing. Do you,
what do you enjoy people fighting around
you and doing that installation versus
saying, fine, let's say everything
is wrong in the universe today.
How do you find the right things
in people to be able to say,
can we build a better world?
So I think that's my transformation and
in terms of building the brand that we
are building. Great. Okay.
Sorry. I was going to
say, I'd say one thing,
because I worked in a big
company in Intel and Google,
I found the best lesson about
building who you are, uh,
from my boss because you know,
in India you're taught that if someone
would come to me and say, Lakshmi,
you know, you're a great job doing that
out. Oh No, no, no, I didn't do it.
Like Sam's idea or like, you know, he
really helped me or you know, whatever.
So an Intel,
we had something called ranking and
rating where all the bosses have to get
together and then they have to fight
for which one of their people should get
better ranking.
So my boss came to me and said,
you make it so difficult for me to
fight for you. Because anytime I say,
look what luxury? Then they said, no, no,
she didn't do it. You know, Sam did it,
you know, whatever. So
she said, can you please,
when someone gives you a compliment,
can you please say thank you and shut up,
you know, don't say anything else. Because
otherwise you're always this mater,
you know, like, Oh wow, they're all
better than like suddenly you realize, oh,
they all left me. And like, you know, I'm
sitting here being the martyr, you know?
So I think especially women,
and maybe I'm generalizing to a lot,
Indian women have this whole martyr
syndrome of I have to be the one to take
care of my in laws I have
to do and take care of kids.
I'm the one who has to stay home too.
I'm the one who has to do everything. I,
we just get rid of the crap and you know,
and so I always say there are three
things is that you need to show up because
unless you show up,
nothing will come your way.
Next thing you are to speak up or ask
for it. When I brought her to India,
I went to Chris and I said, we should do
this. It was like, wow, okay. If it was,
if I didn't ask,
it's an not an idea that would have
come to him and then shut up. You know,
we should know, show up, speak up, shut
up, we should know when to do what.
And we always do the wrong things at
the wrong time. So no one to show up,
no one to speak up and know
when to shut up, you know?
So I think that bills who
you are it, you know, and,
and the times when you speak up, everybody
may not like you, but that's okay.
The people who like you
will really stick with you.
The others don't matter anyway.
So you know, the three s
[inaudible]
take back the three s Beacopp uh,
funny shops pick up and shut up.
That's the great thing.
I need to reflecting on that.
Go ahead. Go ahead. It's
not just a good thing.
[inaudible] you know,
typically in our middle class upbringing,
you're supposed to be always look up to
your elders, you know, treat everyone
with reverence and sometimes it
does just doesn't work. Yeah.
And my first brush was that coming
from a very middle class background,
I was put into sales and that
to up not in the country,
but nobody will live in Luke up to you
unless you give a few expletives. Right.
Um, so, you know,
it was like a cultural shock and a
functional shock as well in sales.
And then you literally,
you have to show up to make yourself,
you have to speak up to ask for the money.
Yeah.
And then finally you have to shut up
once you've got the order because after
that, if you start
justifying, then you are,
it's a good dog three months. Right.
Absolutely. Okay. Thank you for that.
Um, so I need to do, you also spoke
about consistency, reliability,
dependability for the brand
as a brand for the region. Uh,
how did it go about doing it?
Was it,
once you identify the dependability
is what Hydro Bot will stand for?
How do you go about really building
that top of mind recall? Yeah,
I think,
um,
you know, you have to look
at it from, uh, you know,
and it has evolved over a period of time.
If I were to look at overall Google's
business or go global operations from
India, I think initially when
we started off the operations,
it was more like providing scale.
Um, viva growing crazy. Uh,
we just ran out of people in the bay area,
right?
And I think that's how we came to India
and just to take care of the growth and
the scale, but that can't be a
value proposition beyond the point.
And very soon we realized that and then
we started consolidating and looking as
what are we here for?
So it was a bit of a soul searching
after having expanded operations.
And that's where in I think the
realization happened that, you know,
you need to be very clear of the value
that you're providing as an organization.
And over the period,
I think we shifted it from just providing
resources and providing transactions
and providing support to really pivoting
around expertise and what we uniquely
bring for Google in India to India.
Right.
And I think the answer was
very evident for us, right?
Let's leave this amazing talent that's
available in country, in know country.
And Google is all about a
lot around analytical skills,
around data driven decisions.
And we have that in plenty.
So if you have processes that effectively
leverage is this on top of it,
the fabulous technical talent that we
have, we have a very winning proposition.
So I think that's been the journey and
whether you take whichever function, um,
you know, whether it is Gtech
or trust and safety, RSM, we,
we have been trying to leverage
that and get it to the maximum.
And that's a fair point because we
always tell the teams that your personal
branding for stops with you individually,
then it goes to your team and then
it goes to the larger organization.
So you consistently have to
build on all the three, uh,
some good point on that a little are you
keep talking about using digital media
consistently to check on your brand and
your individual brand as well as your
organization's brand. And as a part
of my work and trust and safety,
our team's constantly educate people
on leaving a digital footprint.
What are you really leaving behind
when you're talking? Because we've had,
we educate kids in schools and we say
that you're leaving something on your
Facebook or on your Google plus
account or anywhere linkedin and seven,
eight years later,
there is a recruiter who's doing a
background check on you and they find that
you have very polarized political
view or very polarized individual, uh,
views. And then they say, oh,
this is not going to match to
our organizational culture.
So we really teach people on how they
shouldn't be leaving a digital footprint
that does not work for them.
So how do you evaluate that?
So a couple of years ago,
um,
I actually came to the realization that
Facebook is the biggest brand building
tool available to you for
your personal branding space.
Every photograph you put out there,
every status update,
every comment on a colleague sort of
friends or a family member's post is
sending view up,
sending the world a very clear view of
who you are and what you believe in.
We share stuff randomly. I, I
recently got an update from Facebook.
They're in the last year. I've
shared some 9,000 things. I was like,
where do I get the time to do it?
But I've done it.
The problem is we don't realize that
there is now no boundary between your
professional life and your personal life.
It is all one fluid,
seamless hole and everybody
at all times is judging you.
So you know,
only the paranoid survive.
Anybody and everybody who is looking at
your life, whether it's your best friend,
your spouse, your children,
your colleagues, your
workmates, your investors,
they are all watching you.
Do not think anything you put out there
is being ignored and therefore you have
a duty to yourself to speak. Could,
you know, show up and speak up.
But most importantly to shut up.
I think in personal branding
on the digital space,
one of the strongest things that
you can do is stop yourself.
Stop yourself from sharing
that status update.
Stop yourself from sharing that
personal low that you're going through.
Stop yourself from
calling your husband out.
He has pissed you off because
the world is watching.
The moment you realize that the world is
watching and it will have repercussions,
you will automatically start controlling
what you put out there and controlling
is the first aspect to building our brand.
That's a good point. It's a
luxury. Coming back to you,
I know you worked with a lot of people
in the industry in building the brand and
helping them make a story
and they're all low.
Some of them are working in organizations,
some of them in Ngos. How do you feel,
what does the common story in terms
of building their brand for everyone?
You know,
as I said,
one of the things I always look for is
was what is it that makes them them?
You know, actually when we were
all kids, we were just perfect.
We are just ourselves.
And then through the years you learn what
not to do and then we have this facade
of, you know, like for example
I'm sitting in this chair,
I don't know if it's just like this that's
just like this, that's it. Like this.
Which you know,
you're like,
your mind is wandering through 10
different things cause you want to look
perfect and right. And what I try
to work with people on, you know,
be comfortable with your imperfections
because that's your greatest tool.
The point is that we focus on trying to
be perfect so much that we are not in
love with who we are. And I think, you
know, in my conversations with people,
I try,
because it happens with everyone.
You talk to them in our first
like there is this very,
this very focused,
or I want to talk about the four ways
to blah or six ways to play or something
like that. And then, you know,
you kind of get a little,
get a little and then they suddenly
something gets where they become children
when they're talking
about it. Oh, you know,
but when we were building this product,
we did this and then we did that.
And then you're like,
ah, that's what it is.
The place where you become
a child, you, you know,
you don't care what you look like or how
you sound like that's who you are and
everyone has that.
You know,
you just need to find that and bring that
out and say it's okay to be like this.
Yes, I know you're this big
deed president or whatever.
But it's okay to be that here because
there are tenicity referring back to what
you were saying. Um, it's most important.
And I also tell them there's another thing
I learned in theater is that like for
example, if you're in a play,
you forget a line or something,
you're just beating yourself over
the head, right? But you know what?
The audience has no clue. Only you know
that you miss something. So I tell them,
look what if you forget a
line or whatever. Nobody
knows. Nobody is judging you.
You know, just be yourself. If you
forget something, just keep going.
And there's a lot we can fix
in editing, you know, so, so,
you know,
be,
so I think a lot of the story telling a
lot of the personal brand building is to
find that those imperfections in you and
being extremely comfortable with them
and try not to be perfect
because a perfect person is
the most boring to watch.
Torquey totally agree.
I know moving to your wife,
I know a lot of the audience,
so what is about negotiation,
because I think this is a tome we have
a lot of courses on negotiation and
people's life is all about negotiation
from Atkins to your organization,
to your managers, to your peers.
You're always negotiating.
How did your negotiation involved in,
through your career and you've
spoken about something, uh, from
being a selfish negotiator
to a selfless negotiators.
Do you want to talk about that
suddenly? So one, uh, I'm a minority,
so it's in my DNA.
It's part of our upbringing.
But I thought maybe a couple of
stories that, uh, that, that sure.
How I've transformed a
would be interesting. Uh,
when I graduated from a University
of Illinois in the graduate school,
typically they didn't do campus placement,
but during our time, I think we got,
I got offers on the phone
and stuff like that,
but there was this one
that we got on campus.
It was a bank called First Chicago and
they sent a letter to three of us, um,
giving us a job. Right? So I don't
remember, it was like 30, $40,000 a year.
I don't remember the exact figure.
But anyways,
so the HR sends me an email and you know,
the other two people accept.
I instantly responded back saying,
you have no idea who
you send this offer to.
You have no understanding of my worth.
And it was,
I don't remember the exact words,
but it was primarily saying that you
have no clue who you're talking to.
You better give me a better offer.
Right.
And within five minutes I get a call
back from HR. They were shocked.
They were like, they never heard anyone
say something like this before. And,
uh, any, she called me and
said, you should never say
something like this, this,
that, but by the way of my vice
president wants to meet you.
So I went the next day and they
increase my offer by $5,000, uh,
just because of that email. But
I didn't join them anyway, but,
but it was a, you know, when I think
back, I don't have that email. It was a,
it was that time of my life when I was
extremely arrogant. Um, and it was,
it was my way of negotiating
at that point. And,
and I thought it was perfectly fine
over a period of time, I think, uh,
I continued to negotiate in every
form we take your Ip, you know,
but like one of my, uh, classmates in
the class on negotiation in Harvard did,
we all were kept in three d multiple
groups. When we came out, he said,
my God, I thought, you know, you will, I
got the best deal here when I come out.
I find that I'm the most crude,
but you know,
but I think what I have evolved into
is to be able to say that if you really
want to get the best outcomes,
it's more important to understand heart,
what it means to them also.
So the best deals will be done if you
also understand what your open at once.
And I think that comes in with a very
open view of being able to do this.
I've also gone in the middle through
this phase where we had to deal with an
investor. We were acquiring a company
for which we are raising money. Um, they,
uh, it was a very, very tight timeline.
We were acquiring a public company.
There was a certain time
in which you could do it.
We had no money to otherwise buy it.
But the way we had to negotiate there was
to walk away and, and I, and we got it.
But today I think in most cases,
whether it's negotiating with an employee,
whether it's negotiating with anybody,
I first tried to understand what the,
what it means to them. Um, and I
think once you understand them,
then I think it's easy to anchor and
to be able to get the right pieces in,
in together. So I think that
has shown that, you know,
I've gone through the phases of life
where you started hard negotiation towards
being a, to be able to say, how do
you get the best out of everybody?
That's a good point.
I know because a lot of time when you're
negotiating and you're thinking that
they are, the arpanet always has an
opposing the requirement. They don't,
you probably talking different languages.
Would you want the same thing?
So really sitting and talking,
having a fair dialogue helps you really
achieve that. So a, and I would just,
uh,
during lunch discussing,
there is a research done by a lady called
Linda [inaudible] who saw a third of
women don't ask. And they
find that 7% of the women, uh,
attempted to negotiate a new job offer,
whereas 57% of men always
negotiate a job offer.
So she did a little more research
on why women don't negotiate.
And one of the things is women feel that
they suffer from a reputational risk
when the negotiate, how are they
perceived when they negotiate? So, uh,
what is your impression of this research?
This is not something that I'm
generally speaking about. Um,
we in our investor portfolio,
I'm one of the,
as my investor ports around
the most Chiney people.
So he basically tells me the first board
meeting we had, I remember he came,
we had the whole session and then he said,
you know that all of the other portfolio
companies I've been telling them to
reign in their spending
with you, I'm thinking, you
please step up your spending.
So I said, I will, but can you give me
some more money first? And he's like,
I've already given you money.
I said,
but I'm not comfortable spending
till I have more money in the bank.
So you give me money, then I'll spend. So
they gave me money. See, I didn't know it.
He said, my God, you take asking for
money to a whole different level.
And that's when I told him, I said, I
learned this in my career the hard way.
Women negotiating two ways and they're
still distinct patterns of behavior.
How we negotiate.
You negotiate a certain way when you
have something in your hand and you
negotiate a different way when you
don't have something in your hand.
So if you have to job,
job offers,
you see how you go and
negotiate with the new guy.
We full been [inaudible] not [inaudible],
you don't have a job offer.
So please not three there though.
And the one thing that you know,
my dad always told me,
he's like always going like
you have another offer on
the table cause he doesn't
know. You don't have another offer on
the table when you're going to say, Eh,
it's not happening. It's in Dev. We'll
say no. That's another thing women do.
Women either say yes or they say no.
A lot of successful negotiators
never seen no, there's,
you know, I think we can do better. You
know, let's work on this a little bit.
They will never say no. They
will never stop and walk
away. They were, in her case,
it worked and you don't touch
wood, it works. But in most cases,
if you just keep the interest alive and
keep pushing, keep pushing, keep pushing,
you will eventually get to a what?
What's most importantly behave like
you have another offer in your hand.
They don't know any better. No, that's,
that's a very fair point because you
always always have an option if not this,
you have an option.
Options always come and a yeah,
we tend to say yes or no and we
need to get into the gray zone.
Why the men have a problem with asking.
I don't personally
suffer from that problem.
People listening,
it has that and the research also says
they associated with the reputational
risk. Like they ass
asked too many times. You
call aggressive, you know,
I mean you have to deal
with labels and I think we,
somewhere in the bottom of our hearts,
we all want to be liked by everybody.
We don't want to be called. Yeah. Oh,
that aggressive or just very, very upset.
He said, Oh, you know, when
she's so sweet, she's so, we
want to hear those things.
Be a good girl. It'd be
a good girl. Yeah. So
like you want to be universally
like, I mean, mine is,
apple was always the
opposite problem to her.
I'm like this completely useless teleco
man, you know, can ask for anything.
So it's like, it's always like, oh yeah,
take care, take care of. They don't,
it's like, I'll do it for free as a
show up. I mean, it's sort of like this,
and I learned this from somebody.
One speaker I was talking to to
come here and then he said, oh,
I would love to come to India.
And it's the only thing is I need
$100,000 donation to my NGO only then I'll
show up. I'm like, wow. Uh, it also,
but he was like, he's pretty good.
He said, it's not for me, but if I'm,
and he said something very interesting.
He said, if you want to say joy,
don't do anything for money, but if you
do something, you are, you get paid.
You know, it's sort of like
you don't need to do it for it,
but somebody should value your time.
So I think I've learned that
now when someone asks, okay,
you donate something to our foundation,
then I'll come. It doesn't matter,
they donate five rupees or 500,000 it
doesn't matter what you're doing and show
me. And then I'll say, I'll tell
them that I was, you know what?
You think I'm worth it.
I'm watching kind of a thing.
But I think some of it
is finding the balance.
If you're the one who's like,
you know,
who didn't have any fear or the rain and
if you're the one who was kind of very
awkward asking, you should push yourself.
It's amazing what you get when you ask.
I am always amazed by it. I'm like,
Oh really? Okay. And that's fair.
We should always be asking.
It gives a word to your dog.
And one more thing I want to say is the
thing I've always learned that helps me
as a tactic. Pretend that you look
like everybody around in the room,
you know? So if I'm in with,
you know, especially at Intel,
most of the things is
like 15 white guys and me.
And I think I look like a white guy.
I mean I don't think I look
like anything different.
And I think I talked like them and
then I move into a room off, you know,
2015 year olds, I think I look
like them, talk like them.
So you just have to think,
you look like them, you know,
you don't look anything different.
You're not anything different.
That's a good tip.
Um, so I did, this was for you
because as a business leader,
you've oftentime made offers to senior
leaders in your organization and both men
and women. How many times have you seen
a woman actually come up and negotiate?
You said any incident that sticks out and,
or
you wish we were hiring more woman because
then the opportunity for negotiation,
it's been one of my big objectives here,
but he does admit to that 57 versus 7%.
I can't get me,
I can't remember the exact stats,
but men usually nine out of 10 times
has ended up in a negotiation with this
thing and each one has their own style.
One will be like slamming the phone.
I have also myself slamming the phone on
Google offer, so I completely resonate
working in north India
[inaudible]
but the, the, the person whom
whom I slammed and I respect her,
she is currently the director
of HR director, Flipkart.
She was the head of recruitment and she
was equally aggressive so she didn't
call back. And then I'm like, okay,
all right.
So,
but uh,
but usually
it's the case that, um, men
do negotiate a much, much,
much, much more. I, and, um,
I wish, I, I think, you know,
as I was saying that I think it's,
it comes to um,
this anxiety maybe or some
worry factor around, Ooh,
if I say no, what would
happen? Right, right.
Or would it be interpreted in some other
way? And that's something, you know,
some of the fabulous women leaders
that I work with, you know,
they used to give it a dab. Yeah. Right.
So I think that's the spirit
with which we meet too. Yeah.
You know, I, I just wanted to say
this one of, I have a very, very,
a very esteemed colleagues, the very
senior female leader, and she always says,
I'm not in this for the money.
And I saw disagree with,
I think women are a lot of times
you'll hear this from women a lot.
I'm not doing this for the money.
What are you doing it for?
Incident to passion and the
money. Oh, this consequence.
Yes. I think, I think you're wrong.
That's a great negotiation tactics.
[inaudible]
I'm not doing it for the money,
but give me what I want.
Yeah,
yeah. Don't smell bad. I want to say
it. You know, especially for women,
I worked in the NGO sector,
corporate, everything.
It's very easy for them
to ask for somebody else,
but it's very difficult for them to ask
for themselves. It's just something,
not some women, this is like a
psychiatric saying. My friends,
I do it all the time. You
know? It's so easy for me to
walk in and say, my friends,
any doctors, none is doing this, give
$1 million, and then I'll go in and say,
Oh yeah, my Saturday, it doesn't matter.
You know what I mean? It's sort of like,
but I think we have to get over this
thing of it's okay to ask for yourself,
your, your health, your
money, what you need.
There's nothing wrong and asking for it,
but it's a,
I still have a huge mental block to
it. I feel kind of odd, but I have to.
It's sort of like this you hate doing,
but you have to do it.
It's sort of you pushed yourself.
That's one of the things I have
to push myself a lot. I mean,
people don't know me don't believe that.
But I do know one creeped up.
I think we got some really good tips.
One is pink that you have
options when you're negotiating.
So that gives you a lot more power to
negotiate, ask because we don't ask,
you will never know what they're getting.
And Paul does believe in your value
because if you believe that you are
vulnerable, the other person when
started believing that you're valuable.
So asked with that.
Can I just add one to that? And this is
a very Google centric view maybe. Uh,
and this is beyond salary. Yeah.
Yeah. Uh, it's, I think, uh,
in the business context and you know,
we are negotiating every day.
I think what has worked for
me a significantly is, uh,
and what I keep saying all our
leaders is where that one Google hat,
because, uh, today you are
representing this function.
Tomorrow you're representing that
part of the business. But if you,
and I say that, that, you know,
step back and if you were familiar,
very few are so under what we'll do.
We did thinking about it.
And then suddenly it makes you open up
with a lot of possibilities and u s and
that's where the new connect with
your opponent or your adversary,
whatever objective you want to port.
But that's where in the meeting ground
kind of happens because many a time I
think we are negotiating but we are all
on two different pages and the the, the,
the Twain shall never meet
kind of a syndrome. Yeah.
Which, which is a question what is right
for the users, what's right for, yeah,
exactly. Not Fair. Um, so I
think we, we ready to close,
but I do want to open it up to
audience questions. But before I do,
I just want to talk about, just summarize
thinks that, uh, everybody has said,
so I know you spoke about
personal branding, evolving,
building it on your strength and building
a consistent story and you do that
through your poems,
poetry writing to,
you spoke about using digital media and
writing as well and really working on
people perception value
system and pushing us forward.
A great anecdotes there as
well. Um, you've always, I,
we've even in the past when we beat in
meetings to always spoken about Google as
a brand,
Google hydropower bot as a brand and
spoken about pos system can asking for a
consist and consistently
asking for the right message,
which is dependency and
dependability and luxury.
You have been amazing in terms of
working on story telling with people and
really all,
all the anecdote you gave about
being authentic and being out there.
Before we close,
I just wanted to each of you to give
one thing that you'd like a corporate
audience too.
Oh,
you live with,
I think I always look for, it doesn't
matter. Corporate audience or whoever.
I think it's wonderful to
find amazing heroes around.
Doesn't celebrate them.
So one of the things that bugs made
when we say who's your role model?
All our role models, a western or
the cricketers are there film people?
We don't look at amazing stories
that are happening around us.
And I think instead of looking
for inspiration somewhere else,
I think the inspiration
is right around you.
And I think it's the person who comes,
works in your house, your neighbor,
you know, your local
grocer, whatever it is.
I think we need to find great
stories around us. That's what I,
I value.
I know.
Uh, I think it's most important that you
know who you are well and if you need to
help him, that will help you
do it with a genetic test.
Very smart.
So what I'll share here is not
necessarily for a corporate audience,
but it worked for me because I'd
spent 14 years in corporates. Um,
there's a lot of things that
we all want to achieve in life.
A lot of us have bucket lists
in the stuff we want to do.
We always wondering about how it's
going to pan out, where we going to be,
how is life going to play out?
I just,
I keep one more time for myself
itches every two, three years. I see.
What do I really want to be good at? What
do I really want to be good at, right.
Kick asset. And then how do
I figured out how to do that.
And that's why my life has been fairly
exciting because every three years I say,
now what do I really want
to be? Kick ass? I know.
I figured out how to be kick ass at it.
It just keeps life exciting and why?
So figuring out what you want to be really
good at and then I'm figuring out how
to get there, the journey
to be interesting. Huh?
Okay. Yeah. I think, uh,
somebody is a be who you are,
uh,
be self aware and, um, you know,
live with your strengths rather than
Franklin on your ads that just focus on
your strength and God alone.
Correct.
Thank you so much. Thank
you. [inaudible] one Lakshmi.
We've been trying to get
them for a long time,
but finally we could get the
schedules to match. Really,
really appreciate the time you've
taken to talk to Googlers. Thank you.
[inaudible].